[Music]
so
okay let's go e4 well it's not it's an
office okay so he plays the perk
and i've sort of ranted about not
recommending the perk to people and
hopefully i'm gonna
demonstrate why that is uh so he can
play e5 here okay that's the philidor
that's that's a version of the philidor
and
a lot of people don't understand in this
position why
is it that white doesn't take on e5 and
then we can take the queen
forces king to lose castling rights the
problem is
when you've traded queens the king
losing its castling rights it just
isn't as as powerful
as when the queens are on the board so d
takes e5 is a move
but we're just going to keep developing
with knight f3 which is the main line
then we're going to develop okay so he
takes we're obviously going to take with
the knight
and there are several ways that we can
go about playing this position we can we
can go for long castles we can go for
short castles
the way that i like to play this is
actually to put the bishop on d3 to lend
some more reinforcements to this pawn on
e4 that's our only central pawn
so it makes sense to develop our pieces
in a way
such that we keep the spawn protect now
what should we do with the night should
we take it
should we drop our night back what do
people think this is actually quite an
instructive moment
so i actually think we should not take
it
and after the game i will explain
exactly why i believe that now both
moves are fine
we're dealing here with marginal
differences but i do think it's an
instructive moment in decision making
we're going to drop our knight back and
then continue developing the basic of it
the long and short of it is that by
taking
we give him more pawns in the center and
we help him
uh orchestrate something like d5 which
here would not be possible
now the reality is we've got a bigger
share of the center than our opponent
does which means white is slightly
better
and we've got very free development so
after the game i'll show uh
some more reasons why i didn't take but
quite an instructor now how should we go
about expanding
in the center we can of course develop
our bishop but
we don't actually always have to do
everything strictly by the book
we can start expanding a little bit in
the center and on the king side we've
developed enough pieces to where this is
fine
uh we can deal with this bishop a little
bit later we don't always have to
you know complete our development by the
book at this level uh you've got to be
able to improvise a little bit
and and know when to do something a
little bit more ambitious
and he's developed relatively passively
so we can afford this uh
you know especially so
rook e8 now a couple of things that we
could
do here right we could push this pawn to
f5 now the downside of that mode is that
we would give him the e5 square for his
knight that's a very nice central
outpost
um so in this kind of situation it's a
good idea to make a
general improving move now what does
that mean
first of all bishop e3 is absolutely
possible but i'm thinking of a slightly
more aggressive move
let's look at this queen for a second
it's just sort of sitting there on its
initials can we put it on a
on a nice little square where it's
controlling both
yeah good job guys queen f3 is exactly
what i'm thinking about
bishop e3 might have walked into knight
g4 which would have been a slight
tiny bit nasty so you'll see this very
often f4 followed by queen f3 is a
typical idea
what we're basically doing is is we're
waiting for him to show his cards right
he might play d5 and then that'll
that'll help us understand how we want
to play this
uh but there are certain positions where
you don't know exactly how your opponent
is going to arrange his pieces there we
go
see now there's clarity to the position
we know that he's
he's lost his cool he's lost his
patience and of course as as
we know we don't want to take here and
play into his hands that's why we played
f4
we played f4 partially so that we could
meet e5 with
with d5 with e5 forcing his knight back
okay for some reason he just gives up
the pawn i don't see what his
compensation is going to be
now which way should we take on e4
and this is actually a tricky question
that i'm asking you guys
so both moves are fine
now the case to be made for taking with
the queen
is that we are threatening checkmate but
that's actually not the reason that i
want to take within the reason i want to
take with the queen consists in this
move
i saw that he was going to play g6 and
it looks like this battery has been
blunted
the aaa battery has run out of power
he's going to go bishop f5
but there is a tactical idea that we
have here if you notice how strong this
battery is can we break through let's go
f5
now i'll put it this way guys this is
not as simple as it looks
he's got what i think is okay so of
course he falls for it bishop takes
a five we take with a rook this is very
typical
attacking exchange sacrifice and he
simply has no defense
to queen takes h7 which is going to be
checkmate if he tries to move his king
our bishop would come out to h
he's probably going to do that would be
my guess uh king f8
all of the checks are covered not that
they even do anything
so it there's actually i think a
semi-refutation to the move f5 which was
very complex
i'll show it after the game he simply
resides good
now first of all why not take on c6 so
there's a couple of things here first of
all as i hinted at the during the game
do you guys see how even though yes it's
true we make more pawn islands yes it's
true
doubled pawns but you guys know that i
always urge you to put pawn structure in
proper context
pawns may look ugly but they may
actually be fulfilling a very important
role and now
d5 is much easier to to organize and
this is just like a bumper on a car you
know it's going to be hard for me to
to to get past that the other thing is
that he gets a b
file for his rook so if i ever try to
develop my bishop he can tickle me with
rook ba
and he can potentially either force me
to make my rook passive
or make the knight undefended and and
all these things you know
taken together they get annoying so i
decided to drop the knife back
now why can somebody explain to me why
d5
is not possible here or why is it
inadvisable
and another very typical tactical yeah
evil now is correct so ed
takes takes and then in the end the
queen hangs very typical scenario bishop
h7
uh if you've solved your fair share of
chess.com problems
you should you should be able to
recognize this pattern very quickly
and if you haven't then well here's your
introduction to the discover
check and by the way if you've gone d5
with black
and your opponent is taken and you have
realized that you've just blundered
it's not too late to double back right
you can go 95 and give up
on it's better than putting your head
down and stubbornly going for the losing
line so f4
queen f3 and players in the 17 1800
rating range
have a hard time at times just keeping
the tension i've talked about it before
what my opponent should have probably
done is a move like bishop f8
which is a typical move in these
positions dropping the rook back
allowing the rook
more influence over the center black is
slightly worse here black is passive
but he's also very solid and it's hard
for white to prove anything immediately
i would have probably developed the
bishop
and uh you know the battle would have
continued but he kind of lost his cool
with d5
knight e4 and actually after f5
what would have been the annoying
sequence so instead of taking on f5
does anybody see what else he could have
done
it's a move that he makes with tempo he
could have gone bishop d5 now that
doesn't seem like a big problem in and
of itself because we can move the queen
away
but what you should notice here is this
rook on e8 there's two things the rook
on e8 and the fact that as soon as you
play the move f4
you absolutely somewhere in the back of
your mind you need to tell yourself okay
this diagonal has been weakened so i
need to watch for bishop c5
as weird as it sounds you have to make
that mental note to yourself very very
quick very very
early in the process so that you get a
better chance to see tactics
and if you're alert to that then you'll
see knight takes e5 that's not a blunder
this puts the queen in the x-ray of the
rook and combined with the fact that we
played f4
we lose the queen obviously i would not
have taken on e5
uh white can play f6 and the attack
continues but the position gets a lot
more messy
than it would have been if we didn't do
this so that's actually why if i was
playing another gm
i would have taken the bishop uh seeing
that line because now i'm threatening to
win a second pawn
and i've just got a very compact
position and i'm up upon so basically
that's the reason why
i think f5 is a little bit objectively
dubious
and i just verified that with the engine
yep bishop d5 was very strong instead
he falls for it right bishop takes f5
and after gf
we would have played rook takes f5 it's
the same exact effect
there's simply no defense to the
devastating queen takes h7
does that make sense to everybody
any questions and please don't be afraid
to ask questions i i say this a lot and
i mean it every time
we're here to learn and i want to make
sure everybody is included and
it doesn't matter if you're 200 or 1200
uh i
you know you should never be afraid to
ask anything boring democracy thank you
for the sub
all right uh perfect
uh if king f8 we would have come back
here and now let's check me
so basically that that's how we would
have met that
all right well we're 1800 let's continue
um let's continue
so so far you know i i like the time
control even though the games have
gotten more complicated they're not like
okay 2100 wow okay this is a serious
dude
never mind it's not a serious dude yeah
i think he aborted because we were a
little low rated
that that happens okay marco 981 damn
it would have been a good opportunity
but we'll get there we will get there
and he plays the modern
and we've encountered the modern a lot
right the modern is where you fee and
kettle the bishop immediately it often
transposes into the perk
but he plays something called the
gurgaons system it's like a cross
between the karo khan
and the the proper modern black prepares
to go d5
there's a lot of ways that we can meet
the gurken say but one system which is
often very underestimated
is to get the bishop to c4 immediately
the idea is to stop him from going d5
and this is a very common mistake that
people make he simply puts a set as oh
let me prepare d5
what has he not noticed here what very
subtle move can i make now
in order to cement the weaknesses that
he's created with this move
and i'll show um
i'll show a game that really
influenced me that's a boom and look at
this juice right there
he's got to go d5 now we take on passant
but now look what's happened as a result
his bishop is passive he's still got a
weakness on d6 he's brought his queen
out early instead of developing
his position is just going to be very
very cramped he's going to have a very
hard time developing naturally
so we're going to continue our
development of tevarium thank you for
the prime
we're going to continue our development
and
in this position if we look at the
tension between the knights
by playing knight d5 he has relinquished
his control
over a very nice central square which we
can slam our knight into
and of course you guys can see that
potentially we could access d6 now how
should we continue here
how should we continue developing
actively very typical move
it should be on the top of everyone's
mind we could play c3
but let's play a little bit more
ambitiously let's try to induce f6 which
would be
a horribly weakening move thank you
these nudes for the prime
appreciate that 3 a.m support guys
loving the energy
as we move toward 5 000 subs can't
believe it
knight f6 okay so he's pinned himself
it would be great if we had a chance to
apply pressure on the night
unfortunately we don't
so what we need to do here is realize
okay um
his position is super passive we need to
sort of lay it on
and we lay it on by and you guys are
seeing this move by centralizing our
knight
and then look at the disparity in the pc
he's got to play age six
and he doesn't do it and that's going to
cost him tremendously because
we need to have what i call a wish list
and this wish list right is
it has to be updated on every move i
want to do this
okay and this might not be possible one
move
but if you keep kind of mulling that
wish list over in your mind
now you see as a result of us putting in
the 995 we can bring the queen out to f3
and his knight is going to simply be
lost and once
we take the knight okay we just take on
f6 the knight is def even if it wasn't
defended
and he gave up his fiance bishop well
thank you for that
uh even if we didn't take the queen we
would tr we would be able to deliver the
lobster instrument well that was pretty
simple
um but basically his big mistake was was
this movie six
and uh this is something that you guys
should be very attentive to this idea of
like
cementing these dark squared weaknesses
exists across a pretty wide range of
openings believe it or not
and there was a very famous game uh by
tigran petrossian believe it or not
against a very competent player where he
demonstrated
how bad it can be to allow a weakness of
this
sword game that i was referencing
petrossian against pacman it was a grand
master
and pogman does something very similar
to you guys see that he has created
these two weaknesses
guess what move petrosian plays here
pacman didn't realize that he was
preparing it by playing rookie one
what does petrossian do here
he plays e5 exactly same exact thing
pachman plays d6 much like our opponent
did
and you know black has all of these
weaknesses now that he's got to deal
with
and petrossian starts harassing him much
like we did you can see the same moves
being played knight e5
bishop develops with tempo it's the same
elements and petrosian one
very quickly so you can see the
generalizations
that we can make here now if he doesn't
go d5
then we can get our knight to d6 that
would be even more disastrous
but basically we you know we just
developed naturally we attack his queen
now he should have moved his queen but
um
now using an idea from earlier in
the day we can try to chase his knight
away by first moving our bishop back and
then advancing our pawn
to remove the knight from d5 so he's in
huge trouble already
but here it was his last chance to go h6
and forcibly uh and the pin although
it's still very very bad
bishop f6 and queen f3 comes to mind boy
oh boy if he has to take this
and look at these squares the rook comes
in this is absolutely devastating
why did you choose queen f3 overnight g4
asks as roseanne
yeah so knight g4 i was a little worried
about knight pd7
although here we could have gone queen
f3 so it was equivalent but
the purpose of queen f3 first is if he
goes knight d7 we can take the knight
um i think you're i think uh
we can just tolerate it king kara why is
f6
ask snow a new 200 such a weakening move
for black well it's just sort of the
general effect if you look at this move
visually right
it weakens the e6 bond it blunts the
bishop if he castles there's just going
to be more
air in front of his king right there's a
sense in which
he's just just look at this move right
everything is
everything here just kind of becomes
weak and that's all i mean right it's
just a visual thing
almost and in particular this pawn on e6
is a sitting duck
because the e-file is semi-open so when
you're judging pawn weaknesses
pawn weaknesses are especially
disastrous when there's no
opposing pawn on the file and which can
be attacked so if there was a white pawn
on e3
then the pawn on e6 would not be such a
big deal but because the rook can come
to e1 it has a direct line of fire to
the pawn
which means that we need to be very
careful before we make a weakness like
this yeah if he goes g5 i drop it back
but all of this creates even more
weaknesses you give up the pawn
so this never works right when you push
pawns like that you almost invariably
create too many weaknesses
even if you end up winning a piece your
position often remains
so weak that it's not worth doing it uh
just
you know just because you won't be able
to contain
all of the weaknesses as a result let's
continue
can i play the modernist block sure
i i don't i wouldn't mind doing
something like that uh
showing how it should be played because
the modern used to be one of my main
openings so i am going to play the
modern which i've never done before
yeah it looks like this guy's gonna have
some connection problems
now the modern as the name reveals is a
hyper-modern opening hyper-modern
openings i remind you
they really began in the 1920s when
there was a group of chess players that
included rehard retsy you know the ready
opening
and they said you know why is everybody
saying that you have to control the
center with your pawns
i don't think that's entirely the case
here's what we're going to do
what we're going to do is we're going to
let our opponents control the center
with pawns
then we're going to attack those pawns
from a distance with pieces that we put
on very specific sheltered positions
it's like trench warfare
we're going to put a bishop on g7 we're
going to feed and get of that bishop
we're going to you know we're going to
provoke all these moves
and then we're going to attack that
center with our pieces that's the sort
of rationale behind the hyper modern
openings thank you hydro cow the prime
yeah this guy is having bad connection
and okay i'll give him a draw uh
i offered him a draw i obviously don't
want to take his rating
given his internet he's declined it okay
well i guess in that case we'll have to
play
um yeah i'm not sure why he declined it
i think he didn't see it
so well what do you what is the point of
jesus well the point is is to do what's
called a fianchetto that's an italian
term which means to deploy the bishop
on the longest diagonal on the
chessboard and you can understand
right just intuitively that the bishop
controls mathematically speaking
more squares when it sits on the long
diagonal
and in addition you can see that even
though he's occupied the center
our bishop now immediately applies
pressure on that pond
so now we have to develop our pieces in
such a way as to apply
consistent pressure on his center while
also
developing our pieces in a healthy
fashion that's a hard thing to do which
is why
modern's a hard opening to play well
okay i'm sorry he lost on time
so we're just going to have to move on
thank you
for the sub with zako91 okay moving on
hopefully we can oh we're playing he dog
so we'll play another modern
uh and and let's see if he goes e4 to
transpose if not we'll play the king's
indian
uh maybe i should have just started with
the kingston so he plays the london
system
and i'm going to play the king's indian
setup against the london system to show
you guys
how to deal with it with the king's
indian setup i know he can play e4
and i'll explain later the
transpositional issues
now the thing is here the thing is
interesting
we haven't developed our knight to f6
and we can actually use that as a good
thing
why is that a good thing because it
might be easier for us to prepare the
move e5
striking in the center now we can't play
e5 immediately
because he's got one two three defenders
on the square and we've got only one
two attackers how can we prepare the
movie five
and how can we prepare it in such a way
that after e5
d e we don't allow a queen trade
knight d7 that's a very typical king's
indian move
it's more common than going knight c6
because knight c6 keeps that line of
negotiations open between the queens
which might result in us
losing castling rights after we go e5
now we can go e5
yeah you can play c5 in these positions
too but it's more king's indian need to
go for the e5 pod break that's more
principled
now a couple of things right first of
all
let's not go knight f6 because that
would blunder the pawn
but we still need to develop the knight
and we need to be very careful about how
we do this
uh one option is to develop it to e7
another option is to reinforce the pawn
on e5 preemptively
and then deploy the knight to its
traditional square on f6
how can we deploy how can we defend this
pawn preemptively
and i don't want to hear anybody say f6
because you know where that leads
we can play queen e7 actually we're
following i think a game that i played
in
2013 exactly in this position so now
we keep our options open maybe we'll
play knight h6 knight f5 as
uh as one person suggested it depends
what he does
okay so he's allowed us to go knight f6
which means we will
uh it's not this isn't like that
theoretical but i've i've definitely
seen
games like these before so now we have a
nice compact position pawn on e5 is
protected
and uh well we'll we'll see what he does
but um i mean for white you know
he needs to also complete his
development so he's probably thinking
about where to put this bishop
no i don't plan to castle queen said
that would be a little bit too much
uh because that would involve me
fianchettoing the other bishop it would
be
interesting but let's play it more
traditionally by castling
now um obviously we have the question of
this bishop what should we do with this
i just mentioned it but what should we
do with this bishop how do we develop it
because remember if we move this knight
uh we might drop the pawn on e5 we don't
want to do that
and that's where the fiance is so good
fianchettoing is really good when the
bishop can't develop along it's sort of
main diagonal because there's some sort
of traffic right or there's a piece that
cannot move
that's where fianchettoing comes in so
double fianchetto both bishops are
fianchettoed
crisscrossing the board i kind of like
those types of setups
knight h5 was possible for sure there's
different ways to play this position
we're doing it in a more traditional way
we're sort of developing
and there's nothing wrong with that but
you could also play it a little bit more
creatively
so the movie e4 would be a very
instructive mistake and i'll explain why
we actually might be almost following
that game i played in 2013. i'll show
you guys what i mean
so the move e4 yeah would have been
a little bit weakening okay
um welcome to all 3000 you'll be
finishing in about 15 minutes though
so where do we go from here what's going
to be the plan of action well it depends
on what he goes h3
again no need to reinvent the wheel
let's
simply identify pieces that are not
doing anything and bring them into the
game
exactly rook d8 is a start
and while we're doing it right and we
don't want to go rookie
though rook e would be unnecessary
because we have enough defenders on the
pawn already
or do we because here's the thing if we
look at the position carefully right
you guys can see that we're occupying
this d file so wouldn't it be nice if we
could move this knight out of the way so
that the rook could actually do
something on that d-file
well there's a problem if we move the
knight immediately we drop the pawn on
e5 that's a problem we've already ran
into
so we need to solve that problem before
we move the knight from d7 and some of
you have already suggested
ways that we can do it we can go knight
h5 exactly
the point is of course we want to take
this bishop and ruin his structure
but the main point of this move is to
open up the bishop's defense of the pawn
now we can go knight c5 now we can go
knight c5 and we can
allow our rook better control the d5
it shouldn't blood my bishop but but but
again uh
sometimes the position gets complex and
not every one of your pieces will be
ideal
uh but you can see that we're sort of
opening up our controller but this
bishop is super nice it's sort of
really sizzling through the board it's
it's it's a good bishop
and um isn't the bishop still pressure
well yeah our bishop is defending a very
important central part remember i've
said this many times
one of your pieces or more can be
performing a defensive role there's
nothing wrong with that so we have
several ways that we can go about
he's actually made a mistake he's
blundered upon now what knight f1 has
done
if we look at all of our pieces what has
he allowed us to do
what has he allowed us to do absolutely
and we don't do this to ruin his spawn
structure we do it to ruin the pawn
structure because his king is there
and now we have a fork it's a very
unusual fork how do i find it
undefended pieces you should always be
looking out for them
this is an undefended piece and pawns
are included in that equation
so we see several weak bonds have been
created as a consequence of the trade
and combining these observations the
bishop and the pawn
queen to h4 comes to mind attacking the
bishop attacking the pawn
that's a pretty disastrous loss for him
because his king is going to get caught
in the crossfire
okay so it's not only important as a
standalone concept to look for
undefended beats but particularly when
there's been a big time trade
right when you've ruined a structure
like this you should expect
that there will be new weaknesses that
are created which might be the subject
of a fork
so you exploit a previously undefended
piece and something that's just been
created
bingo let's take the pawn and now
we're going to hatch a plan to continue
the king side attack obviously we're
attacking on the king's side
so knight g3 um
well if we take the knight well there's
no need there's no reason not to take
the knight let's let's clear up some of
the tension here so we can
better understand the situation and now
we need to find a way to
as i say add some tabasco sauce to the
king's side
and tabasco sauce can come in various
forms it would be nice if we had a rook
left so we
really don't have a rook lift because
there's too much pawn traffic
so that leads us to the thought well
okay if there's pawn traffic we might as
well use our pawns
and so the move f5 comes to mind right
we just drive the spot to f4
we clear some of that pawn traffic let's
get our queen back first
and that opens up the potential for a
rook lift through f5
thank you rasheed appreciate the five
months
man okay
so he stops us in our tracks question
you ask yourself
immediately when a pawn is pushed like
this
what weak squares have been left behind
and also there's there's many ways many
ways in which we can go about this
e4 very nice guys good observation
skills
but um i'm going to show you guys a
slightly different approach
which is to use your pawns as battering
rams right this pawn and f4 looks like
it's
solid as a rock but what can we do to
try to get this pawn out of the picture
so that we can then go f4 and continue
the attack
it's a typical idea g5 is absolutely
correct
now what makes me think that i can get
away with such well this isn't even
really a sacrifice if he takes on e5
after f4 just intuitively you should
realize
that with a king like this there's just
no way he's going to survive
we could trade queens here that wouldn't
be the worst idea but obviously
we want to end the game with a checkmate
so we're going to drop the queen of g6
onto a square word x-rays the king
i didn't just choose a square random
now we don't even need to play a four we
can collect the pawn
first uh no need to rush with that with
that move now we can go f4
right so so when you can collect the
material back there's no need to force
yourself to sacrifice
okay he gives us a check now the problem
is going to be that if
his bishop moves away from g3 what move
are we going to have to end the game
well and hopefully our opponent will
allow us to show this
of course we go f3 typical lobster pins
or idea winning the other bishop with
checkmate
and that's over he's got to give up this
bishop and the attack rage is on and uh
yeah the game is over so one simple idea
really did it in
yep f3 okay so
again we don't need to rush to take the
bishop uh let's actually bring some more
beef to the g-file okay now we have to
take it
okay let's just simplify now notice that
there is a line of fire to
uh to the king so we can just take a
bunch of this stuff
okay he's threatening bishop e5 so let's
cover that and checkmate with the knight
sorry i had to go a little bit fast in
the end
okay that was an interesting game so
here let's actually compare
uh that game i referenced uh that game i
referenced you guys from 2013 let me see
if i can find it
all right so basically um yeah actually
it was exactly the same thing
this position was reached in one of my
games and and he went c3
so very very similar as you guys can see
queen e7
literally oh my god i think this was the
exact same position
yup so with the difference that my
opponent had his bishop on e2 and e dog
had his bishop on c4
so literally i did exactly the same
literally exactly the same stuff and i
did go
e5 and get my knight to d3 so you can
see that if you
if you take your game seriously you can
learn from them
and you can apply them directly to you
know to your blitz scheme so i had an
inkling that that was what i was doing
but i didn't remember how similar it
actually was uh
so in any case b6 defean kettle the
bishop
but basically everything we did was was
very much uh
very much straightforward and e49d3
becomes an idea here
it's exactly what we practiced for and
knight f1 was the big mistake so edog
could have considered b4 attacking the
knight now what
nice tactical move does black have in
this position
yeah so i don't know if you guys mean g4
or b4
we'll consider both so b4
attacks the knight we don't
automatically move our knight we ask
ourselves can we counter attack one of
his pieces
we actually can what move can we play
bingo e4 we attack his knight if he
moves his knight we have knight d3
and if he takes twice much like in my
game we have c5
winning the night number one
number two if he takes his knight um our
knight then we take his and this pawn is
like a flamethrower
right it's it this pawn is going to
disappear but it's going to take a big
chunk of the king side security with it
and this check comes
white's position is completely
devastated not to mention we can just
win back the pawn
if we want it what does the computer say
your accuracy was 99.9
i don't think so um my accuracy if
you're curious was
no no definitely not 99
95.7 good but i'm sure some inaccuracies
were committed
now if he goes g4 then that just creates
a huge weakness i mean look at how much
it weakens his king we can just drop our
knight back
and uh even if we give up the pawn that
doesn't matter
because we've already done actually we
have a tactic here
oh black is a very pretty tactic here
noticing that this knight is overloaded
what can we do to it now if we take the
knight then the other knight replaces it
but that's what should set your brain
emotion aha what if we take that other
knight
queen takes we take this knight if the
knight takes then we take the bishop
we've got two pieces for a rook and a
huge attack
so basically well queen h4 was a fork
takes
get these pawns back g5 using the other
pawn as a battering ram
trying to dislodge the f4 pawn right
and uh we could have absolutely gone 94
as well trying to get a rook to d2
many roads lead to rome here and uh
it was it was probably just as good if
not even better but i wanted to sort of
uh you know to go after him more more
directly
so basically that was what if he had
placed the bishop on h4 instead of h2
uh well he he couldn't have done that
right because uh because we would have
just taken it
but maybe there was a different moment
oh yeah so he could have gone to h4 in
fact he probably should have
but here and when you have to deal with
a with a situation like this
what do you guys think i should cover on
f6 with
so rob please stop i'm i am active on
youtube and
let's be productive yeah bishop f6
because the bishop is kind of bad anyway
and uh trading that piece is kind of
good for us now i know we create a
little hole here
but at least we've traded off a piece
that's sub sub optimal right
now some of you guys are looking at this
and saying how did i know to play g5
doesn't this weaken my own king
and i always repeat the same thing here
you can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs
in chess at some point you have to take
risks
right you can't have it all against good
players
you'll have to take measured risks such
as yes
slightly exposing your own king could
this backfire it can
has it backfired in my career absolutely
but that's just part of the beauty of
the game
is making those judgment calls okay
[Music]
you